[Music]
she's not your traditional member of the
royal family but then again neither is
her hubby Prince Harry let's talk about
this for a second the Duke of Sussex
spent over two decades rewriting the
royal rule book with his rebellious ways
and now he's married to his perfect
partner in crime was it love at first
sight I think it was for starters
Megan Markel is a former Hollywood
actress plus she's biracial and she's
divorced
a first for the royal family icing on
the cake yeah sure Camilla parker-bowles
was a divorcee as well but at that point
someone's Prince Charles Megan again
she's an independent woman of her own
thinking she's a breath of fresh air and
she seems determined to do things her
own way
her recent no photo policy at Wimbledon
case in point I was just photographing
Serena Williams for the next thing
little tap on the shoulder a very very
polite royal protection officer said
would you kindly not take photos of the
Duchess she's here in a private capacity
when the Royals are at Wimbledon they
are usually photographed you are there
to watch the tennis but you are also
there to be seen by the spectator that
she and Prince Harry appeared to what
they cake and eat it on privacy the way
they're raising their son Archie is
another example of how the Sussex duo
are determined to play by their own
rules
withholding details of his birth from
the media and forgoing the traditional
photo shoot on the hospital steps are
just two ways they bucked tradition I
think really the key reason Megan has
chosen not to do the photograph outside
the hospital is because she simply
doesn't want the pressure of having to
look photo fabulous after she's just had
a baby of course there's also their
desire to raise Archie out of the public
eye I think Harry and Megan are very
keen to maintain maximum privacy for
their child moving forward something
they attempted to do in the early stages
of their own relationship they were very
clever about keeping below the radar but
once Megan and Harry went public the
Queen began making shocking exceptions
to the Royal rules
it might well be the first royal fiancee
to be invited to Santa hammock for
Christmas the Queen has really gone
above and beyond it's always been the
case in the past that only married
couples attend really and we can't talk
bucking tradition without bringing up
Meghan in Harry's 2018 nuptials we've
definitely seen Meghan shake things up
so really care about what I do from her
partials Ola walked down the aisle to
the speech she gave at the reception
this was a real breach of tradition
usually the bride doesn't talk Meghan
often breaks tradition especially when
it comes to her fashion everything about
this outfit was super daring I mean we
have that incredible off-the-shoulder
gown it exposed so much of that glorious
flesh but you know it felt distinctly
unroyal a criticism some also had about
the pink Carolina Herrera number she
wore to her first trooping the colors
this off the shoulder dress has caused a
bit of a storm Meghan's also been known
to forego a certain preferred
undergarment once or twice the Queen is
known to have certain preferences that
includes new tights or pantyhose she she
doesn't like bare legs you need to get
through your head that I'm a grown woman
and that I'm not a damsel in distress
that needs protecting we love Meghan's
fresh take on being a royal and how much
Harry embraces it
Harry has followed in Diana's footsteps
and I think I think he probably does see
quite a bit of his mother in in Megan